well [__] it it's out let's just talk
about
it a good [__] move it works yeah
[__] it works let me see that thing let
me see that thing man cute this is one
Soju dude original Korean Spirits
distilled from Rice yes is it distilled
from anything else but rice or is it oh
that's a crazy picture right
there oh I have a
vagina what's up dude I was the first I
I
know no I I just was about to say
something very
serious sorry sorry no no it's all good
don't look at it dude yeah it's hard not
to but okay um can I you know what's
hard not to yeah and I thought your lips
were
good his lips is that gay what if I see
your you guys are so cute that's a good
photo of you guys that's a good photo
that's a really good photo we got store
at the club appreciate you put up that's
his part yeah I don't know that was his
launch party that was his launch you
were in K Town and you got recognized
more than dumb I don't know not this guy
I did last night dude no I mean I don't
doubt it I mean you you what's up dog no
well and I was just talking about this
in the um in the cars like he's been
you've been around for like 25 30 years
like I I I watch Mad TV in elementary
school so and you've been relevant
you yeah I'm not that old I'm not
that it actually it's about 20 to is
that's a legendary you know what I
mean good I will I be you know I was
surprised about this part cuz I brought
Bobby and he did stay a pretty long time
at this club environment someone has a
video like someone put up a story that
was me I put it yeah where he's like
dancing in the middle dancing by himself
in front of the DJ yeah I was dancing by
Myself yeah because I'm the oldest guy
there by 20 years n n there's older
people there bro I didn't see them they
are and the girls they don't look at me
and I [__] you too you guys always
surviving that [__] right like oh come
on
suun G to be they're not girls aren't
looking at the oldest person at the club
be honest is Hab the right way to say it
no that's
not how do you say it I want to learn
Korean go ahead yeah
yeahi harabi yes thank you that's what I
said earli but
faster all right so that how about this
hanim oh yeah that's perfect
yes throw me some words let me see if I
know
um [__] no there's no way I barely know
that you barely know that what I don't
think I know that go simple dude what
the [__] in a game show they don't go
with a [__] difficult one that's well
it's Buddha but anyways what about what
about ipur oh you should know that one
iul I don't know it oo you you don't
know that no what is I lips lips oh oh I
know IEPs
yeah yeah what what give me another one
last one last one how about that how
about this
pangu God Dam hopefully that that was a
cute ass one though that was not even
vulgar it was just super like cute you
know why it was a tiny one I can I can
control it hey I wanted to sound like
that you wanted to sound cute for that
one [__] all of all the people that
can control their [__] you are not one
of them no
farts [__] you no oh my God Bobby you've
had so many accidental things I've had
to clean up there's no way you wanted I
just [__] my pants in the now what are
you talking about yeah he's bad in
testin you you didn't want that one to
sound tiny right because it sounded like
really cute yeah I think you're right
because he went in a little aggressive I
think he thought it was going to be like
thunderous I think I prematur I prematur
did it he did yeah it wasn't fully baked
it wasn't it out of the oven too early
for sure yeah but still it made a cute
sound anyway iur one last one go ahead
oh he said no that's deep cut okay let's
go simple guys simple k k yes K you know
that one Kon you know that dog no
oh bro you you know Kon I don't know Kon
you don't know Kon what is it egg I
don't know egg you love a Kon you've
ordered egg at a Korean restaurant can I
have egg I don't want get on wait I I so
I have a qu so okay uh oh easy no no I'm
just because let me say something to you
what you're you're about to spell some
[__]
boy he just learned it he just learned
it I just learned it right he just
learned that word no I I'm just
wondering like were you born in the
states yes yes American through and
through okay I have a question yeah you
got follow up to that your mom speaks to
you in full blast Korean do you not
understand anything she's saying no she
says it she must have said egg before no
no no she says like um Bono
oriso what oh that's your brother no no
what Pono oiso where's the bathroom no P
oh pongi or what's P nothing that sounds
like someone's
name I thought that's why I was like
it's your brother's name hak hak yeah
school I know stuff like that um no but
she wasn't
like no no a pop yes poo I even I get
that but I hear her speaking like long
sentences to you that's what I I'm
confused by that for so this many years
you just been speaking English to her
while she's hitting you with Korean
you're not soaking anything in you're
not just trying forgot you know J you
being rude I'll tell you why can I tell
you why can I I'll tell you why because
you went there right and live you live
in Korea now right so do you think that
if I lived in Korea that I would know
more than I know of course and that's
that's why I'm asking cuz when I first
went I I was I didn't know [__] either
so that's what so that's what I'm saying
you you were very um you have an
opportunity to do it and I never had the
opportunity no% how old were you when
you were when you went I was 18 for the
first time like to actually live there
yeah so it's been 18 years now so I've
been living there for 18 years but how
much Korean did you speak when you were
first mooved there probably not probably
like it would be the same thing my mom
would speak to me in Korean and then I
would reply back in English so you know
I would I would know things like like P
or like I8 or like where's the very
simple things yeah like hak that's why
the funniest thing about it is in
America like the only Korean person on
TV was Bobby who doesn't know [__] about
Korean or doesn't speak the language
which is pretty funny honestly
wow no not in a bad way I I
saw no but he was raised by Korean
parents bro that's like he's Korean no
you're Korean I'm not saying doesn't
take away your Korean if I was
full-blown Korean you think I would have
got that show nah or or or or is it
because I've like you know
I've I'm sort of a crossovery kind of a
guy I would grew up in the suburbs I
understood their language and what the
whole vibe is we needed that right
exactly so you know ease up maybe a
little B I I also have like how was it
like way back then just being like
almost like dud it's not 3,000 years
ago like way back wrote The Dead Sea
scroll all that what the [__] you
talking about you mean 20 years ago no
yeah but still I'm talking about for
Asians like in just entertainment that's
like when there's no